a component for a machine tool appears
layer for layer printed in plastic Hagen
Costin sean is a pioneer in this area he
spent the past 25 years working with 3d
printing technology it can reproduce the
most complex shapes and structures
jordan says 3d printing is only just
getting started he believes its
development will revolutionize the
working world one day designers won't
need to know about conventional
manufacturing procedures they'll just
know which component they want to design
and 3d printing will then implement that
one-to-one designers won't have to think
can it be mailed can it be made with an
injection mold all they'll need to focus
on is the function of the actual
component by the hair strands and I'm
futsal ball tov a vision of the future
that his team is already living here
they're printing individual components
of a diving torch manufacturing them
through printing ensures they're
absolutely watertight and ideally suited
for the job but only a small number of
torches are being produced when it comes
to the large-scale series production
used in the automotive industry or an
aircraft construction things aren't so
easy when cozening was clean in major
industries it's quite a long process
getting new materials approved the
materials used for injection molds or
other conventional forms of
manufacturing can't always be used in
the same way for 3d printing as a result
the new technology has been slow to
catch on in industry German industrial
giant Siemens has made some progress
these gas turbines are destined for
Bangladesh where they'll be used for
producing electricity the combustors in
the turbines contain nozzles that can
wear out and so they need to be replaced
from time to time Zeman's now uses 3d
printing to produce these parts helping
to save time
this additive manufacturing as it's
known has long since passed the trial
stage at siemens inside the printing
machine a laser cuts the parts out of
the production material this allows
complex shapes to be produced easily
they actually make the nozzles work more
efficiently but for larger spare parts
this method is problematic I don't
believe that we could produce the
housing for the gas turbines for example
in a cost-effective way using 3d
printing they are made of cast iron and
way around 50 tons not what the way the
technology is today anyway at the moment
3d printing is limited to components of
maybe 500 millimeters by 500 millimeters
by 500 millimeters in large scale
factories this innovative technology
soon reaches its limits when
manufacturing these turbines employees
still operate the drilling and cutting
machines so 3d printing is at least not
turning the working world on its head
overnight the high production costs are
a problem hakan cost and sean believes
it'll take another 10 to 15 years for
the technology to really break through
in industry the problem is that a
printing machine like this one costs the
same as a medium sized house so about
200 to 250 thousand euros and every kilo
of this material costs around 400 euros
that makes components that are a bit
larger much more expensive material for
conventional injection molding costs
about two to four euros aquilo slide i
feei will volcano but business is
growing rapidly the 3d printing industry
is currently worth 5 billion euros
worldwide that figure is forecast to
quadruple by 2020